نعود الى خبر استئناف في تركيا وروسيا
الدوريات المشتركه في الشمال السوري حيث
نصلي الضوء اكثر على سياق هذه الدوريات
وابعادها ومرجعيتها مذكره التفاهم الروسيه
التركيه الموقعه في اكتوبر 2019
كيلومترا عن الشريط الحدودي القوات
الروسيه وحدها تتحمل مسؤوليه التامين 20
كيلومترا من هذه المنطقه الامنه في العمق
السوريه وصولا الى المناطق الخاضعه لسيطره
الوحدات الكرديه التي تعتبرها انقر ذراع
حزب العمال الكردستاني
امل منطقه المتبقيه وهي بعمق 10 كم من خط
الحدود فتؤمنها دوريات عسكريه تركيه
وروسيه المشتركه بمقتضى اتفاقيه سوشي وفي
البدء كانت الدوريات المشتركه تتخذ اربعه
مساره اساسيه ابرزها في الريفين الشرقي
والغربي
لمدينه عين العرب كوباني بمحافظه حلب ثم
ياتي استئناف الدورات المشتركه في سياق
جهود لتفادي العمليه العسكريه البريه التي
اعلنت تركيا انها ستنفذها ضد مواقع ما
تعرف بقوه سوريا ديمقراطيه في مناطقه
شمالي سوري
التعامد العسكري التركي في شمال شرقي
سوريا لم يكن سلسا في كل الاوقات حيث
توقفت هذه الدوريات عده مرات اخره دوريه
مشتركه بين القوات الروسيه والروسيه
التركيه والروسيه تم تسريرها يوم الرابعه
عشر من نوفمبر الماضي
عموما سجل العام الحالي انخفاضا في معدل
تسير الدوريات المشتركه حيث لم تتعدى
ثلاثه دوريات شهريا مقابله نحو سته وستين
دوريه مشتركه العام الماضي بمعدل اكثر من
خمس دوريات في الشهر
اما اول ودوريه المشتركه بين تركيا وروسيا
فكانت قبل ثلاث سنوات وتحديدا في الاول من
نوفمبر عام
2019 لنقاش من اكثر في هذا الموضوع ينضموا
لينا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي اذا استولفت
الدوريات المشتركه في الحسكه بين تركيا
وروسيا ما الذي يعني ذلك
يعني هو نوع من التناغم مع التوجه السياسي
الجديد الرئيس اردوغان قبل سنوات كان يرفض
بصوره مطلقه
مجرد الحديث عن التقاء بالرئيس الاسد قبل
عده اشهر كان هناك تلميحات ثم حدث
اجتماعات امنيه اليوم
يتحدث صراحه بانه تحدث مع الرئيس الروسي
عن احتماليه عقد لقاء ثلاثي روسي سوري
تركي وان كان مشروطا باربعه مراحل
وباتخاذ اجراءات من الجانب السوري ان يكون
اجتماع لقياده الاجهزه الامنيه وزراء
الدفاع وزراء الخارجيه ومن ثم لقاء القمه
او لقاء القادم ولكن ذلك يعتمد على بعض
الطلبات محاربه الارهاب ابتعاد قوات اسد
الى غير ذلك اذا هناك تحول في اتجاه ضوء
البوصله التركيه تجاه الازمه اييه السوريه
لماذا لان هذا يعني ان العمليه البريه
التي ترفضها واشنطن وتتحفظ عليها موسكو
والنظام السوري وقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
او مطار القدس الدينارديه تم التخلي عنها
لا هو لم يتم التخلي عنها لا يزال هناك
التلويح بها في هذا اليوم كان هناك قصف
وقريب من عين العرب وفي بعض المناطق
الاخرى دعني اقول له قلنا منذ البدايه بان
العمليه البريه لا يمكن ان يتم تنفيذها
دون الضوء اخضر امريكي اولا روسي ثانيا
ايراني ثالثا الدول الثلاث
مواقفه متباينه الموقف الامريكي يرفض
بالمطلق اي عمليه ضمن منطقه مسؤوليه
القوات الامريكيه الموقف الروسي لا اكثر
ليونه
وقدم بعض العروض التي رفضت منها الانسحاب
17 كيلو متر في منطقه عين العرب كوباني
همم الانسحاب من تل رفعت الى الشيخ مقصود
من منطقه
بهذه العمليه ما زال مستمرا رغم كل هذه
التحفظات نشكرك من عمان اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكريشي